I'm gonna be black here we go here we go
team black now let's try Sicilian okay
open Bishop b5 Bishop c4 Bishop b5 let's
go with this second time I'm doing this
at least on stream let's see how white
reacts to it this time I'm going to play
a six sooner for those of you aware of
that video I'm referring to many of the
things that you're seeing right now will
eventually be uploaded to YouTube
channel the bishop cannot play to a 4
unless it wants to be trapped in a very
similar way to how you would see the
Noah's Ark trap take shape so now I just
move forward I don't have to worry about
this see 3d for idea which is something
that in the game i played this variation
again in the game i played against Alan
chest where I played 95 that was an idea
that white was trying to run forward
with again don't I don't have to worry
about that but now I don't want to allow
this now this night move may seem out of
play but you'll note now that the C file
has been opened maybe he looks to get in
to see for a typical idea is to get a
night on to this square so maybe it
turns out to be not so bad and maybe
this bishop isn't this idea well this
bishop took two steps to get here so i
think i think i'm doing quite alright
now i'm considering not Knight f6
because of just e5 so i'm considering
queen here b5 bit should be seven let's
see d 6b five or queen c7 or my
candidate moves queen c7 seems very
flexible I'm a little bit afraid of like
night moves here or something
no I maybe I should do this yeah let me
do this right now Quincy seven I'm
neglecting my king side this this has my
concern a real lot because in just a
blink white is going to be castled i am
still three moves away from before I'm
castled many times just being a single
move back from castling if the position
opens up you could be in rough shape I'm
three moves back okay a six I guess
looking to just stop the pin okay that's
that's got to be what it is initially I
thought it's to support be four but
that's just dropping the night so I
don't have concerns about that's just
that's strictly preventative so maybe
before this Bishop tries to get on this
diagonal I play b5 Bishop b7 let's go
with that although no wait a second is
it going to be a sack here I should be
able to deal with that I want to make
sure I want to make sure i get my bishop
on b7 if I played Knight f6 f4 if f4 is
played I want to meet that with d6 and
then after Bishop f3 i have to i always
be concerned about this advance and you
know if I'm delaying this it this idea
of going with my queen side then you
know there's this e 5 advance hitting my
knight and my rook but now maybe I could
get some more instead of going with this
maybe I could just get my night out or
should I just swing the back completely
around here now I need to get a little I
need to get a little closer to being
castled also another thing i want to
point out is when i'm looking for chess
quotes to kind of post to not kind of
but i'm looking for chess quotes to post
to the facebook page one of them that i
came across recently was won by tal
something something to the effect of
like whenever whenever he was something
like when he sees
when his opponent is still uncal DRT
regards that or he already read he
regarded that as what regarded that as
like a precursor for an attack yeah he
was always looking for something to
really mix things up if the his opponent
was uncanny seeing that I'm still a
couple moves away from castling King
side at least I should certainly have my
attention and it does but for right now
night c4 he doesn't really have anything
other than to just jump in here and I
can pick up the bishop pair by doing
that however if Bishop if not here
Bishop takes Queen takes my night gets
kicked away but maybe I'm quite all
right with that yeah I'd be quite
alright with that in fact my opponent if
they're going to give up their light
square Bishop and follow up with
something like a five then that means my
unopposed light square Bishop increases
in mobility it has a direct sight of f3
I don't know if taking what the pond is
best I don't know if I could really make
use of the B file I like just having my
queen in a very strong position so I
don't know that this is really going to
turn it to be an inconvenience to have
my kick my night kicked away I could
just be responding with the night to d5
we're going to see so this turns out to
be what this Knight a5 to see for
maneuver with how white played it I
guess it's quite alright for me I don't
have any issues it just turns out to
backfire in I gain time we are castled i
guess i don't know if i want to counsel
Queen side I could do this pawn push
maybe I should yes actually I should I
was considering moving my bishop but I'm
not going to I do have this square
covered and that's an important detail
because of the battery on this D file
but I was considering just Bishop to e7
but why not do this push this is going
to be the more aggressive square I don't
know that the night could just be
reacting I don't know that it could just
move right away maybe it should maybe
this pin turns out to be too strong and
I don't know that there would really be
anything better than to just recapture
with my [ __ ]
if pond take so I'm going to pre move
that we're about even on time and now
the night is going back home and I don't
know that I even take this pond actually
maybe I do yeah let me take that poem
okay now that this is going to be a
problem opposite sides castling there's
the the B and C files that have opened
up still two moves away from castling if
b3 I might even be able to play a two
okay my Queens hit I'm not concerned
about I'm more concerned about
development than I am concerned about
maintaining the bishop pair also another
train of thought right there is to not
be so fixated with well to really get
the move back in an open position like
this I want it to be back to my move and
this seems very purposeful rook to c8
however is a night here going to be an
issue no it's not so let's play here and
it now threatens just Queen takes Knight
there is a pin 95 is met with Queen a 2
which is threatening made on eight a one
and also just grabbing on a three I
believe I could kick this night away
given time I could just push this pond
maybe could be taken but that's very
risky at this point already with the B
and C files opened up this rook is not
contributing this night well he's not
doing anything if he gets kicked away
then all right ok so the queens are
being challenged here I I see my king as
being the safer of the two if i go here
night c5 is that going to be a pain huh
it might maybe I just I'm gonna go for a
trade now let's go with this for a while
that I was thinking that I had to I had
to move my queen or something so okay
well we're not going to have an attack i
was thinking this but i didn't i
couldn't work out the things with the
night jumping here so i'm just going to
take ok
this is this is getting crazy now let's
see ok now let's do this pawn push night
here I want to get my night here is that
going to be possible pomp wish I think
you have to if I can make use of this
square right away I think that's going
to be big trouble 30 seconds each d 5
night here pawn push weakens this and I
get into that square quickly hopefully
night moves okay the night can move and
there's a discovery attack against that
okay I feel like this should be just
going to do this i'm dropping upon but i
want my bishop to have prospects on that
light square on this light square
diagonal this is not good 20 seconds
each I could grab that night can I
undermine that night i shouldn'ta
premium I shouldn't have been in pre
move there this is not working out the
ponds gonna push here um do I have to
really take that it's in seconds each oh
no oh no oh no no I need time burners oh
no no no don't grab that pot I almost
just didn't recapture their I only have
the clock this feels like a war zone Oh
excellent game ah man that was our first
time playing excellent game it was man
oh where did the time go let's go back
here flip the board and see what the
story is oh man I really like that game
i like my position to a while there was
some good decisions though my opponent
sensing that their King was the more
vulnerable of the two offering a queen
exchange good good choice I think I'm
trying to get in to see 3d for idea is
maybe a good reaction to this night
maneuver I don't even
how accurate is it turns out to be quite
all right with how the game followed the
bishop taking two steps again just
looking at tempos b5 back to e 2 a-6 is
a move I would play whether or not
there's a bishop or night here so we
have an open position and well I guess
if there's a seat I mean it turns out to
be quite alright for white if I'm to
make a suggestion this a three move I
think turns out to not be a good idea
you know just kind of fast forward and
quickly once you get to this point
there's no way like just right here
maybe even me taking here was not a good
choice but just taking a snapshot of
this picture or of this position
something to avoid it's just not a good
position to be in so I don't know about
the a3 move is what I'm getting at if
you're going to do a three maybe this is
a way to view it if you are to play a
three I think you should be I think it's
but you're better off castling King side
because how i can be opening the
position up on the queenside so quickly
I can use that to pry open the position
with your pawn on a three it's much
easier for me to open a file so if
you're going to do a three I think be a
little bit more cautious about castling
queenside King side is likely the
direction you should be going in um and
so okay yeah so I don't know going
queenside go Kings side if anything but
how I followed up was not the greatest I
was feeling pretty good here I'm still
feeling good here and as soon as the
Queen's coming off maybe I should still
avoid the Queen exchange maybe I should
still go to this square queen a 495
I guess I have to the Queen's are forced
to come off then Queen a four-night here
the Queen defends the pun for one and
the the night is forking the queen of
Bishop and I can't move to a square and
defend the bishop other than going to
see 6 which I guess is maybe still all
right maybe I should have run with that
I should have gone with the idea of okay
I have the safer King I want to keep the
Queen's on the board I'm seeing still
some attack against the king in some way
even though I'm having to meet
counter-attacking those like 95 good
good good good option though still to be
going with the the Queen trade it's the
right idea when you're the side that's
under pressure yeah this is I don't see
an advantage at all right now these
ponds are split but i can't i can't take
advantage of that and this idea here of
me pushing the pond was not good I
should have just planted my night right
here this night was a very annoying and
well we were really rattling things off
quickly here my idea was to get it to
open up this diagonal but if my nights
on e4 I really can't do anything over on
these three squares so that was silly to
think I could actually do something um
yeah so night b5 this is this is a very
tight game at this point I'm losing of
course I shouldn't have done that with
the pun this is just flat-out beat as
you know I only have the clock
okay a good game again Louis 691